[Applause]
[Music]
shortly before being fired on Twitter
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson the
former US diplomat had concluded his
first tour of Latin America
[Music]
this was the first official trip a
senior officer from the Trump
administration had taken to the region
though a few months ago in the summer of
2017 the vice president's himself Mike
Pence had his own Latin American tour in
which he visited Panama Colombia
Argentina and Chile
[Music]
I think we all know that the
relationship between the United States
and Latin America is very very we say
special and by special we mean not very
good but I'm not just saying this
because there are about 60 million
Hispanics living in the United States
but also because of historical
precedence commercial ties and many many
security issues
without going any further one out of
every four US trade dollars end up in
this region however the vice president's
and the former Secretary of State's
tours left many with the feeling that in
the eyes of the Trump administration
Latin America is more of a nuisance than
an opportunity
[Music]
and this might actually be softening the
blow considering everything that Trump
has said since he announced that he
would run for president when Mexico
sends its people they're not sending
their best
no more NAFTA no more nap el hombre del
Peloquin we're gonna build the war we
have no choice we have no choice if we
were to describe the relationship
between the United States and Latin
America today we could say that the
United States is kinda like that friend
who demands loads of things from you
when the situation's reversed they won't
do anything for you a pretty good
example of this is the pretty surreal
Mike Pence talk at all that had
practically no objectives and in which
the Vice President seemed to be more
concerned with trying to prevent the
insignificant commercial relations
between Chile and North Korea or maybe
tries to get the Argentine's to buy pork
from his state Indiana he didn't seem to
have much of a focus on actual
international relations between the
United States and Latin America
[Music]
I come from an agricultural state in the
United States I was governor of the
state of Indiana before I became vice
president and I know the quality of
American pork
[Music]
and you know what China Xi Jinping's
China well they're on the lookout so in
the video today we're gonna see what he
wants what does Donald Trump expect from
Latin America and also well what's
happening with China but first let's
look back at the history
[Music]
America for North Americans
in 1823 the then president of the United
States James Monroe launched what would
later be known as the Monroe Doctrine
America for the Americans although with
time this has become more like America
for the North Americans see this
doctrine this policy defended the claim
that the European states had no right to
intervene in American affairs or in the
countries that were becoming independent
at the time from Spain at that time the
u.s. was protecting Latin America and
defending non-intervention which sounds
pretty good right well just wait a
moment here because there is certainly a
problem
well this doctrine led Washington to do
practically everything in Latin America
or a region that has since become known
as the u.s. is backyard
[Music]
oh yes since James Monroe launched this
perspective the United States has set up
governments has overthrown governments
has financed guerrillas has financed
armies has bought politicians has
negotiated with drug traffickers has
managed to legitimize coup d'etat and
has committed many more actions aimed to
depending on the time period either at
fighting communism or defending other
interests such as some big oil sector
multinationals
[Music]
[Applause]
now yes of course some good things have
also been done especially in recent
years friendly more let's say opaque
relations gave way to a strategy from
Washington that focused more on
resolving internal conflicts
this was the case for example with Bill
Clinton's Columbia plan or George Bush's
trade promotion strategy which led him
to sign no less than ten new free trade
agreements with Latin American countries
and to even propose for all of America
to become a large free trade area even
so relations between Latin America and
the United States they've always been
very peculiar you see due to the Monroe
Doctrine Washington has always felt like
a legal guardian who can decide what's
right what's wrong what's advisable and
what's not advisable however the results
haven't been very positive
[Music]
this is over a year now since Donald
Trump entered the White House so let's
see what the presidents of the United
States of Latin America wants what he
expects and what we can expect what does
Donald Trump want
now it's not going to surprise anyone
watching this video that Donald Trump is
not exactly Latin America's best friend
he seemingly has very little concern for
the region except Cuba Venezuela and
above all while Mexico in fact trump has
so little interest in Latin America that
one year into his presidency at the time
of making this video
he still hasn't appointed someone for
the Assistant Secretary of State for
Western Hispanic affairs this is the
person specifically responsible for
diplomacy with Latin America and it's
quite unusual that it hasn't yet
appointed anyone to this position but
that is not to say that his lack of
interest hasn't made the region
something of a plaything for him nor
does it mean that he doesn't expect
anything from them well let me let me
explain this Trump's first year has been
marked with insults to Mexico mostly due
to is obsessed with building that wall
oh and he's also threatened Colombia
which is something we're going to get to
in a moment
it may be through reimbursement but one
way the other Mexico will pay for the
world build that wall build that wall
built that wall built that wall build
that wall build that wall build that
wall build that wall I love Mexican
people I have such a great relationship
to makes it I hire thousands people the
rich Mexicans they're great people
friends of mine they buy my apartments
well how about some more examples now so
listen to this in 2017 as we saw here on
visual politic Trump moved away from
Obama's openness towards Cuba Without
Really proposing any sort of alternative
also back in the worst customs of
Western diplomacy in Latin America he
legitimized and supported the very
suspicious re-election of Juan Orlando
Hernandez in Honduras
[Music]
and most recently in 2018 is government
decided to suspends the so-called
temporary protected status of a
Nicaraguan wanderin Haitian and above
all Salvadoran immigrants and listen
because with this decision 200,000
immigrants from El Salvador
yes 200,000 will have to leave the
United States or simply become illegal
immigrants we had hoped that if we
worked hard paid our taxes and didn't
get in trouble we would be allowed to
stay
verónica lagunas 39 a Salvadoran who has
two children born in the United States
and these are just a few examples the
list is really rather long perhaps that
is why Trump's popularity in the region
is so so low and when we say so so low
we really mean it is just totally on the
floor I mean check it out in 2017 gala
past Latin American citizens for their
opinion on President Trump only 16% had
a positive opinion the folks here's an
important question the question that we
really need to ask ourselves is does all
this offense does all this poking in the
I mean that Trump doesn't want anything
from Latin America and the answer that
is not at all his government is
demanding several things from the
regions countries especially the
following three
[Music]
first unconditional support for his
foreign policy including his policy on
Venezuela seconds for people to renounce
or curb China's influence and third for
them to take the blame for everything
either by paying for the wall or by
assuming more responsibilities in the
fight against drug trafficking now okay
except for China in the wall the other
demands could really be taken as
actually being pretty reasonable do you
know what the real problem here is
[Applause]
thus that the Trump administration never
put any alternatives on the table they
don't seem very willing to give anything
in return and they do everything under
the you're either with me or against me
approach and the truth is that if we
want Latin America to change evolve to
prosper it needs support and it needs
opportunities like for example more
trade opportunities that was another
Republican President George Bush's
precise strategy and the results were
actually pretty good but okay now you
might be thinking well come on Simon
surely Trump has also proposed some
positive things right well I really
think to answer that question we need to
see how Trump is treating the u.s. is
best allies in the region
[Music]
[Applause]
friends
I think we can say without fear of being
wrong but Colombia Honduras and Mexico
have traditionally been the us's best
allies in Latin America you know what
with Trump in the White House it's not
really helping very much
check out the statements Trump made
while Rex Tillerson was on tour trying
to strengthen ties with Latin America
these countries are not our friends
we think they're our friends and we send
them massive Aid and I won't mention
names right now we send the massive Aid
and they're pouring drugs into our
country and they're laughing at us
Donald Trump yes
Trumpy doesn't give out any names but
there's little doubt he was referring to
Mexico Colombia Honduras and brew on
Mexico he mentioned the war he mentioned
the NAFTA renegotiation there have been
constant attacks since Trump announced
his candidacy and you know how people
feel about Trump in Mexico well
according to polls its 1.6 points out of
10 let's also take a look now at
Colombia the country that my FARC has
historically had the best relationship
with the US
yeah might surprise you but Columbia was
actually the only Latin American country
that sent troops to the Korean War it
also supported the United States in the
2003 invasion of Iraq and this country's
policies have pretty much always aligned
with Washington's interests these are
ink related policies towards Cuba China
and Palestine well not even that
prevented Trump from threatening this
country by considering it
non-cooperative with the fulfillment of
international requirements in the fight
against drug trafficking this is
something that could have serious
economic and political consequences it
isn't only treating an ally who's trying
to solve the problem in a rude way it's
also a grave mistake he's sending a
toxic message to the rest of the region
even if you do what the u.s. asks if
they disagree with part of your strategy
they will act against you Adam Isaacson
coordinator of the Washington office for
Latin American affairs yes it is true
that coca production has rebounded in
Colombia and that the country hasn't
been able to beat the drug trafficking
but threatening the country that has
suffered the most from the war on drugs
threatening the only country that has
managed to improve the situation has I
mean on top of that he's doing it
without proposing any alternative
we've lost our best leaders our best
journalists our best judges our best
police in the war on drugs Juan Manuel
Santos president of Colombia and
regarding Honduras another great ally
well we've already told you here on
visual politic about Juan Orlando
Hernandez is very probable q and even in
Argentina a country that is rapidly
changing something that Washington
should logically act upon well they're
not even acting then Trump demands a lot
from Latin America but he really isn't
willing to give much in return not even
to the United States as best friends in
the region and China and noses
[Music]
why does pursuit
China and the Chinese influence in the
region is becoming a great obsession for
the United States Rex Tillerson himself
used the Monroe Doctrine to say that the
United States has the right to block the
interference of another power in America
but the question is who gave the United
States government that power in the
first place Latin America does not need
new imperial powers that seek only to
benefit their own people Rex Tillerson
allow me to explain this Latin American
countries have all the right in the
world to seek other alliances other
markets and other investments and if
those are Chinese
[Music]
perhaps what the u.s. Department of
State should ask itself is how is it
possible that Xi Jingping
has visited the region more times in the
last five years than the President of
the United States both Obama and Trump
well China is willing to promote trade
agreements and investments while Trump
is determined to punish Mexico build
walls and restricts trade a great
example of this is the shutting down of
the TPP the largest trade agreement in
history which includes among other
countries Mexico Peru and Chile see in
the last Latin American and Caribbean
states community meeting China announced
it would invest 250 billion dollars in
the region in the next decade if the
United States wants to maintain its
power and its influence and continue to
determine the political agenda perhaps
it should include looking after Latin
America's interests in its political
strategy but now it's your turn on a
scale from 1 to 5 how do you assess the
USS influence in Latin America where you
can leave your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video if
you did please do hit that like button
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday also don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching when Mexico sends its people
they're not sending their best
no more NAFTA no more naps el hombre del
Peloquin we're gonna build the wall we
have no choice